so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
of
sunday morning's papers and tonight
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalists and author rachel
shabby
and the former conservative advisor
anita boten good evening to you speak in
a moment first of all let's take a look
at some of those front pages for you
why don't we start with the observer
leading on next week's budget plans with
the headline sunax 5 billion
plan to rescue high streets from
collapse
and it's the budget which also features
in the sunday telegraph
which says that the chancellor plans new
taxes for online deliveries and
freelance workers
and sunday times stealth rise in income
tax to pay covid
bill the headline there the scotland on
sunday has the headline ready for the
fight of her life in reference to
scotland's first minister giving
evidence next week
in the salmond inquiry
here's your mirror leading on the
funeral of captain sir tom moore with
the headline his spirit
lives on and the sunday people also has
a tribute to the war veteran
and fundraiser
and i'm joined tonight by rachel shabby
and anita boateng great to see you this
saturday evening
uh anita why don't we start with you
front page of the sunday telegraph it's
on all the front pages or certainly all
the
broad sheets the budgets on wednesday
and it's going to be hugely significant
isn't it the paper is all taking a
slightly different uh
take on things the telegraph going with
sunac plots
tax raid on parcels and freelance
workers
yes and i certainly don't envy the
chancellor because
i think this is going to be one of the
toughest budgets for a chancellor to
navigate
certainly of the last five years um it's
going to provide as
the telegraph speculates a mix of
ongoing support to some continued
support around you know extension of the
furlough possibly stamp duty holiday
um but also as the telegraph really
focuses on
a real attempt to broaden the tax base
in order to manage what is going to be a
very difficult and bumpy period
economically and the real challenge from
the chancellor which we can see coming
through the telegraph
is that politically and economically the
two cycles you know don't quite match up
ideally the chancellor would want to be
more cautious in terms of balancing the
books right now
so as not to choke off a recovery but
politically
if you wait too late you're too close to
an election to really increase taxes
and that is a fine line the chancellor
is going to be trying to walk
next week yeah he's damned if he does he
damned if he doesn't rachel isn't he and
of course the conservatives promised no
tax rises didn't they i mean do you
think people would understand
given everything that's happened over
the last 12 months if uh if he has to
bend the rules somewhat or bend that
promise
it's an interesting one isn't it because
the public has always consistently
been in favor of higher tax for the
highest earners
and favored favored hikes incorporation
tax as well
and we can see that reiterated now in
the most recent polling
shows that now in the midst of a
pandemic of course
support for um those tax measures
is still there if not more so and i
think that
when we look at uh this budget this week
a lot a lot of it will be the focus for
a lot of it i think will be on
how where is the tax coming from who is
it that's being taxed
now it looks like the chancellor is
talking about
um an online tax so looking at companies
that have done so well
when so many of us have only been able
to shop online
but on the other hand it's it's looking
like he's backing away from a windfall
tax which just does look like a missed
opportunity
um we do not want a situation when the
people worst affected by the pandemic
are hit
even harder in the recovery from it
and a winfor tax is such a great way to
make sure that doesn't happen
it looks it looks at taxing companies
like amazon which amazon uk had 50
increase in sales in the pandemic year
circo
circo a company that got billions um
in prior in contracts using public
sector money
for private contracts um made 36
uh increase in profits this year the
idea that you wouldn't put
a win for tax on companies like that
does seem bizarre
uh anita front page of the observer
again soonax 5 billion pound
rescue plan to stop high streets from
collapse i mean the big fear of course
is uh
employment and uh the issues that we're
going to face
uh this year with millions of people
struggling uh to keep their jobs
the chancellor wanting to offer seven
hundred thousand shops pubs restaurants
etc
these grants and of course it's young
people isn't it who work in the
hospitality sector
who are most likely to suffer i mean do
you do you think this
will go far enough this 5 billion pounds
um i think the chancellor is doing
absolutely everything possible to keep
as many jobs as possible but ultimately
we are in a situation where there is a
huge
unknown which is how quickly demand gets
accelerated through the economy again
once you know the magic date the 21st of
june
arrives and it's really not clear at
this point and we still have the ongoing
threat of possible new strains of the
virus that will hinder
and slow down the reopening of the
economy we're just really not sure
whether households are going to take a
very cautious approach to spending again
when it comes to the summer and knowing
and remembering the the pain of the past
year
or whether they are going to want to
just get out there and spend some of the
income that some families have built up
over this period
so there are so many unknowns in this
and ultimately it's really
whether these um hospitality businesses
end up being viable it's not really
going to be down to
whether they get support from the
chancellor it's really going to be about
whether there is a genuine demand in the
economy
for those services and that really
probably all comes down to
whether and how social distancing
continues through the summer
yeah you make a very good point there uh
look at the front page of the sunday
time stealth rise in income tax to pay
kovid
bill i mean that's the thing rachel
isn't it i mean the bank of england's
chief economist said recently
that we're going to be like a coiled
spring
um that there's a lot of sort of pent up
financial energy and there needs to be
doesn't there in order for us all to get
out
and spend again to keep the economy
going do you think it'll be there
it depends which bit of the picture
you're looking at i think it's
definitely true that there are a lot of
people who during the pandemic have had
an opportunity to
to to save i think they were dubbed um
the sourdough savers by some economists
just because you know people with
disposable
income not having anywhere to dispose it
on the other hand
a lot of people have been really
struggling and really hit in this
pandemic
um household debt has risen during this
pandemic
so again what we're looking at is a very
real risk
that the rampant inequalities we have in
this country
will deepen even further if the
chancellor does not
manage the economy with a budget that is
conscious of that and unfortunately i
don't see any sign
or any awareness of that with the things
that being trailed so far
so when we look at needing to stimulate
the economy i think that is absolutely
true
but some of the ways that you stimulate
the economy is to invest
you invest in skills you invest in
training you might want to look at
raising the living wage
so that people have more money to spend
in the economy you might especially want
to look at doing that for people who
have borne the brunt of the pandemic
carried all the risk in the pandemic so
that we are able to come through it so
we're looking at frontline workers
not just nhs but other frontline workers
they're the sort of people who um
i think deserve a pay raise and it would
be good to see that happen
in this week's budget anita you've been
shaking your head do you want to come
back
well i just think this is just not
reflecting the reality that we've seen
from the chancellor which is that the
inferno scheme has kept a lot of people
particularly in hospitality going
and that is what we're going to probably
see extended through the budget so i
think the chancellor is very conscious
of those people that have been
struggling the most
and secondly on this point about the
national living wage
we've just talked about how much of the
hospitality industry
might potentially go to the wall and how
much they need an emergency injection of
cash
if we combine that with an increase in
the in the national living wage
that might be great for people that
still have their jobs but there's going
to be an awful lot of people
and an awful lot of businesses who will
not be able
to to weather an increase in salaries so
i think the chancellor is taking a very
cautious approach
but we'll see and i'm expecting to see
an uplift in uc for instance which i
think
is really speaking to that lower income
group of people who have really
struggled
over the past year okay i'm going to
have to leave it there i'm afraid we've
got to go to the break
thank you both full coverage of course
of the budget here on sky news on
wednesday
coming up doctors are warning of a
mental health crisis among children
and young people caused by the pandemic
discussing that and more
in a couple of minutes come back time
for part two of the press preview
rachel and anita still with me uh front
page of the
observer rachel i mean children have
really suffered haven't they as we know
over the last 12 months the pandemic
really has been extremely difficult for
for youngsters and doctors now fear a
new
child mental health crisis
sadly yes i mean you're absolutely right
the children have had a really tough
time
over the last year i think it's really
hit young people hard
um and now we're looking at uh
some charitable mental health services
saying that they're seeing a
70 rise in demand over the last three
months
and they're expecting a surge in cases
as uh schools reopen in the coming weeks
um so this is a very grim picture we
often talk about the
um the the the shelving
of health concerns during the pandemic
people not getting the treatment that
they need for various
um conditions and of course mental
health
is a massive component of that um
treatments that people are not receiving
or uh
needs that have become more and more
urgent as a result
of the pandemic so yes a very grim
picture for young people and it is worth
saying as well that
child and adolescent mental health
services were services
really hit by austerity cuts in the last
10 years they were hit particularly hard
yeah of course we'll move on to the
front of the sunday telegraph
anita uh of course many of us still
working from home not me personally but
of course
many many people are still doing that uh
eventually the government will want us
to
uh at least part of the time head back
to the office and this could be an
incentive
flexible rail season tickets
well i think this is almost an
inevitable response to the market given
the reality
that there's so much that's unknown
about how often
and how um able we will be to get back
into the office and i'm one of the
people jonathan who sadly
is working from home and is quite keen
to get back to the office
maybe on a more flexible basis but let's
see the way that office models
change um through this pandemic i
definitely think that the
trains have had a really difficult time
most
i mean the government has spent a lot of
money supporting
economically um a lot of you know for
instance tfl who've come into a lot of
you know financial trouble
due to the massive drop in demand but
really i think it's quite early to be
able to predict just how quickly
we're all going to be cramming back onto
trains again yeah there's been a shift i
think hasn't there in recent weeks
certainly um anecdotally speaking to
people i know who are now sort of saying
what you're saying really keen to start
getting back to
the office um let's just finish uh with
the front page of the
sunday mirror rachel what a lovely uh
picture there of uh
tom of course captain sir tom uh his
spirit lives on his coffin
wrapped in the in the union jack and
i mean what what a man and what a
send-off today
yeah i think it was an incredibly
dignified and moving
uh send-off today we saw um hannah
ingram or his daughter describe her
father captain
sitter more as a beacon of light and
hope
to the world and i i just think that
that's such a beautiful
sentiment and perfectly captures uh
feelings around the world um towards
towards this incredible man
and obviously sending sympathies to
all his family and loved ones